der titel ist kein fake ich werde mich
in diesem video auf droge arten viel
spaß
momentan bin ich ab circa zehn uhr
morgens bis mindestens 22 uhr im büro
plane drehe schneide telefoniere
schreibe und mache einfach alles was es
so zu machen gibt sieben tage die woche
und meistens sogar auch noch länger als
22 uhr das ganze läuft so seit circa
zwei monaten und mir geht es immer
schlechter ich finde keinen richtigen
ausgleich ich bin konstant unzufrieden
unkonzentriert lasse mich von jeder
kleinigkeit ablenken und habe ein
unheimlich schlechtes auf
fassungsvermögen allgemein geht es mir
mental immer schlechter und ich bin
konstant unzufrieden vor ein paar wochen
habe ich mir dann apple watch gekauft
die mich jeden tag aufgefordert hat eine
minute aktiv zu öffnen das hat mir so
gut gefallen und mir gefühlt schon so
viel gebracht dass ich nach methoden
gesucht habe die das ganze auf ein neues
level bringen gefunden habe ich mehrere
methoden die alle auf ihre eigene art
versprechen mir bei meinen problemen zu
helfen ich habe mir vorgenommen alle
methoden nacheinander zu testen um euch
so sagen zu können was wirklich hilft in
den nächsten wochen kommt also jede
woche ein video in dem ich probiere
meinen kopf wieder auf vordermann zu
bringen am anfang habe ich das ganze
ähnlich wie ihr wahrscheinlich auch noch
belächelt aber was wir in diesem
experiment passiert ist habe ich so
wirklich noch nie erlebt die methode die
ich in diesem video ausprobieren werde
es von wim hof der sich selber iceman
nennt will muss ein niederländer der in
vielen verschiedenen disziplinen 26
internationale rekorde hält neben dem
atmen ist eine dieser disziplin eisbaden
wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollt wie ich
mich dieser methode annehme dann lasst
mir gerne in aber grundsätzlich
funktioniert seine methode ziemlich
einfach und startet damit sehr bewusst
stark und viel zu atmen tief ein und
tief wieder aus darauf folgt eine
längere zeit in der man die luft wieder
anhält und das wiederholt sich dann
mehrmals außerdem wird diese oder eine
ähnliche methode von apnoe tauchen
benutzt um sehr lange die luft anhalten
zu können was die methode verspricht
oder was ich mir erhoffe sind mehr
konzentrationsfähigkeit besseres auf
fassungsvermögen und irgendwie einfacher
und klarer zu sein was ist aber im
endeffekt wirklich für eine wirkung auf
mich hatte ist komplett verrückt tag 1
aufgeht atme 1
und aus
ein
ziemlich genau so hört sich das geführte
atem programm von wim hof an und genau
das werde ich die nächsten sieben tage
benutzen in den ersten paar minuten ist
mir noch super schwer gefallen nicht
wirklich darauf einzulassen ich bin bei
gott kein esoterischer typ und hatte am
anfang einfach noch das gefühl das ist
so was in die richtung sei und habe mich
dagegen irgendwie bis hin gesträubt ich
konnte einfach nicht richtig loslassen
das sollte sich aber bei minute fünf
oder sechs des elfminütigen programms
dann ändern
und plötzlich habe ich das gefühl gehabt
alles um mich herum war irgendwie weg
und ich war wie in einem schwarzen raum
fast so wie in einem traum bei minute 10
ging es dann richtig los ich hatte das
gefühl in einem absoluten trance zustand
zu sein fast so ein bisschen wie auf
droge und es war wirklich ein komplett
verrücktes gefühl was ich so noch nie
erlebt habe direkt nach der atemübung
habe ich folgende sprachnachrichten in
unsere gruppe geschickt ich habe gerade
so in elf minuten lang seine atemtechnik
gemacht von so einem typen der mojo das
hat sich am ende angefühlt wie ein
kranker drogen tritten das war komplett
geisteskrank und ich war zwei oder drei
minuten danach noch komplett falsch also
ich habe jetzt irgendwie das jetzt 15
minuten her und ich komme jetzt erst
wieder so richtig klar das ist eine der
ersten sachen die ich hier gemacht hat
direkt danach habe ich angefangen zu
recherchieren um zu schauen ob es leute
gibt die ähnliche erfahrungen gemacht
haben dabei wenig auf nias video
gestoßen und junge guckt euch das mal
ran
[Musik]
eine der drei hauptpersonen vom kanal
namens web ist einfach komplett trippen
und will nimmt sich seiner situation an
und beruhigt ihnen das gelingt ihm zum
glück auch aber auf jeden fall sehr
beruhigend für mich zu sehen dass das
anscheinend normal sein kann und dass es
mehr leute gibt die bei dieser
atemtechnik halt wirklich solche sachen
erlebt haben und vielleicht sogar noch
krasser als ich zwei fragen stellen sich
jetzt allerdings hat es auch die
gewünschte auswirkungen mein tag es
besser verlaufen und zum anderen wie zur
hölle ist das gerade passiert aber
erstmal weiter mit tag 2
und auch am tag zwei arten ich mir erst
mal fertig obwohl ich alles genauso
machen wie an tag eins habe ich
irgendwie nicht dieselbe wirkung das ist
aber auch überhaupt nicht schlimm weil
eigentlich war es ja gar nicht ziel mich
auf droge zu atmen es ging vielmehr
darum über den tag hinweg davon zu
profitieren
ich will aber trotzdem nicht bestreiten
dass ich an tag 2 nicht auch in
irgendeiner art traumzustand war zwar
nicht so stark wie am tag eins aber ihr
seht das ja selber
die veränderungen in die gewünschte
richtung fange ich dann wirklich am tag
drei am zu spüren denn über den gesamten
tag hinweg deutlich fokussierter kann
mich besser konzentrieren und lass mich
weniger ablenken das problem ist ist es
der erste tag und ich weiß nicht ob es
nicht vielleicht einfach daran liegt
dass ich einen guten tag habe oder dass
ich viel zu tun habe
das werden wir in den nächsten tagen
aber sehen außerdem kann ich mich
irgendwie besser darauf fokussieren was
mit meinem körper macht während ich atme
ich merke dass bei minuten 5 und 6 meine
füße unendlichkeit werden also so
wirklich des 40 als werden dass
eisklötze außerdem habe ich das gefühl
dass sich meine herzfrequenz viel besser
kontrollieren kann und das irgendwie
alles viel bewusster machen kann
also ich habe wirklich das gefühl so
langsam kontrolle über meine atmung über
mein herzschlag und mein blutdruck in
irgendeiner weise zu bekommen ich habe
keine ahnung ob das medizinisch möglich
ist aber ich habe das gefühl dass
kontrollieren zu können damit ich denken
kann ob das alles einbildung ist oder ob
ich wirklich einfluss auf mein
herzschlag nehmen kann lass dich an tag
4 meine apple watch mit einem live bild
mitlaufen und sehe dort ganz eindeutig
wann und wie mein herzschlag
funktioniert das wirklich komplett
verrückt zu sehen man kann genau
beobachten wie ich in den atem phasen
mein herzschlag supercross nach oben
fußte auf manchmal bis zu 130 in den
phasen wo ich dann die luft anhalten
sind mein herzschlag wieder drastisch ab
auf weniger als das wo ich gestartet bin
und insgesamt sind mein herzschlag über
die gesamten elf minuten konstant beim
atmen von 130 auf 111 und beim
luftanhalten von 81 auf 68 an tag 5 6
und 7 hat sich während meiner atem
phasen gar nichts mehr geändert also
alles was ich in den ersten drei tagen
erlebt habe hat sich zwar wiederholt
aber es kam nichts neues dazu dafür habe
ich aber wirklich krasse resultate
gespürt dazu aber später mehr erstmal
kommen wir zu einer möglichen erklärung
extrem vereinfacht ist die methode dafür
gemacht den körper mit sauerstoff zu
sättigen und das verhältnis von
sauerstoff zu co2 im blut zu erhöhen
durch der höhe vom sauerstoffgehalt im
körper erhöht sich auch atp
adenosintriphosphat atp ist der
universelle und unmittelbar verfügbarer
energieträger in zellen ich habe keine
ahnung wovon ich hier geht also ganz
vereinfacht gesagt erhöht man durch mehr
sauerstoff seinen energielevel und das
hilft uns zwar nicht zu verstehen warum
wir uns wie oder warum ich mich wie auf
droge gefühlt habe aber es hilft uns
dabei zu verstehen warum wir unser
eigentliches ziel aktiver agiler und
aufmerksamer zu sein damit erreichen
können wir haben einfach in dem moment
mehr in
und wenn wir das morgens machen starten
wir einfach wahrscheinlich schon so gut
in den tag dass wir vielleicht noch den
ganzen tag davon profitieren und das ist
auch das was ich in diesem experiment
erlebt habe in den ersten paar tagen hat
es mir jetzt mal so viel spaß gemacht
mich auf droge zu atmen es hat aber
nicht dazu beigetragen mein eigentliches
ziel zu erreichen nach vier oder fünf
tagen habe ich das wirklich erreicht und
ich habe wirklich das gefühl dass wir
nachhaltig dabei geholfen hat mich
länger über den tag und einfach besser
zu konzentrieren und mich auf meine
arbeit zu fokussieren da das im direkten
verhältnis dazu steht wie glücklich ich
bin je nachdem wie viel leistung ich
bringe und wie gut ich meinen kram
abarbeiten kann war ich tatsächlich
diese woche wieder happy a und hat mehr
geschafft als in den wochen zuvor also
tatsächlich hat es wirklich was gebracht
glaube aber auch dass es in meiner
situation ich habe will ich jetzt vor
mir selber behaupten keine depression
oder so sondern ich habe einfach gerade
eine schlechte phase in der mich die
arbeit und so überrumpelt dabei hilft es
allgemein einfach sich schon der
situation klar zu werden um darüber
gedanken zu machen und sich in
irgendeiner weise mit sich selber zu
beschäftigen also hätte ich mich zehn
minuten hingesetzt und einfach nur
entspannt und gedacht okay so du kriegst
das alles hin
das wird schon alles dann könnte es auch
sein dass mir geholfen hätte wie sehr
jetzt das atmen genau dazu beigetragen
hat dass diese woche so viel besser war
als die davor weiß ich nicht es hat aber
eine menge spaß gemacht ich habe mich
auf droge geatmet das war sehr nice und
ich werde das wahrscheinlich auch noch
weiter durchziehen auch wenn in den
nächsten wochen noch andere projekte
kommen die mir dabei helfen sollen ein
bisschen glücklicher zu werden wenn ihr
durch dieses video auch glücklich
geworden seid dann lass mir gerne ein
leichter abonniert nicht damit kein
video mehr verpasst wir sehen uns
nächste woche ja ja und ich weiß nicht
ob ich das irgendwem empfehlen würde ihr
habt ja gesehen wie mode von iris jury
aussagen
ich weiß nicht wie sehr man alleine
wieder aus dieser situation raus kommt
ich weiß nicht wie sicher das ist ich
habe keine wirklichen scientific proofs
dafür gefunden dass das nicht schädlich
ist oder das ist wirklich etwas bringt
lass es am besten einfach sein ich
verlinke euch trotzdem diese atemtechnik
und weil ich glaube bei diesen zehn
minuten kann auch nichts passieren alles
auf eigene gefahr